so producthunt has been blowing up what
do you think made them so successful so
product has an interesting story because
my contributing author on the book is a
guy by the name of Ryan Hoover who was
working a job at a start-up he was was
ok with he wasn't super happy about but
he Ryan emailed me one day and said hey
you know I've been reading your articles
on TechCrunch and I like this consumer
psychology stuff how can I help you so
we got together for lunch one day and I
said look I've got all these articles
I've been thinking about putting them
together in a book do you think you
could kind of help me make them into
this cohesive book as opposed to a bunch
of disparate articles and he did we
worked on it for several months and he
did a fantastic job I really enjoyed
working with him well there's nobody who
understands the hook model second to me
better than Ryan and the next thing that
Ryan did after we worked on this book
was to start product on three and he
designed product on from the get-go with
the hook model in mind now the company
is doing phenomenally well I'm lucky
enough to be an investor so full
disclosure I happen to be a fan for a
number of reasons but yeah the app is
doing incredibly well because it was
designed with this hook at the early
days of the product design and of course
Ryan and his team get 110% of the
question of the credit for this I have
the easy part of just talking about the
theory but they had to actually
implement it but I think they say
themselves a lot of time and and and
found the right thing sooner by using
the model and out hi as a new
entrepreneur can do the same right so
again I'm a little biased here but I
think it starts by taking some time to
figure out your hook before you've laid
down any code before you've done any
wireframes just to think about what the
core experience is that you want to turn
into a habit and then ask yourself do
you have the fundamental characteristics
of a habit-forming technology by number
one do you have have you identified the
internal trigger do you know your users
itch number two what's the external
trigger that gives the user some piece
of information to do the intended action
number three what's the intended
behavior and how can it be made as
simple as possible number four the
variable reward is how are you giving
the user what they want scratching their
itch and yet leaving them wanting
or and then finally the investment phase
the fifth question is what's the bit of
work that the user does to prompt the
next action to load the next trigger and
a store value in the product and if you
can answer those five questions and you
you have this core hook in your mind you
can design accordingly and it becomes
much easier to build the right thing
sooner can I use the same model on
existing products sure so it's a little
bit more difficult because as you know
once you've built the product it's kind
of hard to change it right you've you've
laid if you've done all the architecting
you people have worked hundreds of hours
on it it's harder to change and so what
often times I see people doing is I'll
get emails from an entrepreneur or a
product manager and they'll say to me
look you know we've been struggling with
this product and until we read your book
we couldn't figure out why people
weren't using it right we put so much
effort into building it and we didn't
know what was going on the cut a few
customers were telling us they really
liked it but even they weren't using it
so then the book can become a diagnostic
tool right we can figure out oh this is
why people aren't coming back
we haven't identified the right internal
trigger or the external trigger isn't
effective the action is too difficult
the reward isn't very rewarding or we're
not asking people for the investment at
the right time so then it becomes a
diagnostic tool then you can of course
you know correct from there so what
hooks does prog hunt have sure so the
the I think product hunt has a great
hook it's something that people use on a
daily basis I think their their hook is
very reliant on this external trigger of
getting an email so you get this daily
email from from producthunt that says
hey here's the latest and greatest in
technology products the action then is
to open the email and to reveal the
variable reward now the variable reward
is this uncertainty about what what is
it what is the latest and greatest right
here you're looking through all these
various products to see one that might
be interesting to you you click on one
of those products if you go to the
product hunt discussion page there's all
these discussions happening about people
you know talking with the founders of
these products there's this great
community formed around these products
and the more you interact with that
community by commenting by sharing
things to that community by creating
collections all of these things load the
next trigger and
store value so the next time it won't be
your daily digest anymore now it'll be
an email from oh this is your friend who
you trust who just posted something to
product times prompting you to come back
again right that's something that a
piece of information that you've given
the company that can now send you
through that four steps of the hook once
again and the more you use the product
and this is where I think investors
think the company can can grow outside
of just technology is that it learns
your tastes it learns what you're into
and so hopefully over time that hook
expands into all different kinds of
interesting industry areas so
understanding me and giving me a more
relevant results right exactly that's
part of this this investment phase